hello and a very Happy New Year to
everyone a new year is the time for new
motivations and new resolutions and I
thought that this is a good time as any
to discuss something very important
which affects all our lives our work our
studies and our relationships and that
is how we handle social media now this
is an of repeated topic there are many
many discussions all around ironically
even on social media itself that how
social media is harmful for everyone
especially for
students now I want to take a slightly
different stance I don't want to say
that social media by itself is harmful
rather how we manage our habits and our
own usage with social media that is
probably what is a little bit
harmful and in some cases probably even
toxic so in this video I want to go into
some detail into the various aspects of
handling social soci media now I admit
that I have my own problems with using
social media so in no way I'm claiming
to be a guru in this matter rather this
video is probably as much meant for my
younger friends my students all around
as it is a note to my own self for the
future so let us start the first aspect
that I want to discuss is something
which we have all suffered from it is
the the problem of scrolling mindlessly
so this is Doom scrolling as they refer
to it in social media itself so we have
all been guilty of this we open our
social media account whether it is uh
YouTube shorts uh Instagram rails um
Twitter feed or Facebook feed or
whatever uh you use and then we open it
for just a second maybe for some light
entertainment just to take a quick
glance at it and then we start scrolling
and then we forget uh what we are doing
and we just mindlessly keep on scrolling
and scrolling and before we know it
maybe 1 hour or even 1 and a half hour 2
hours is gone just like that so we have
all faced this I'm sure so uh the
problem is that this kind of a scrolling
is of course by its nature a big sink of
time but what is also harmful is that
after we are somehow done with this
after we are fed up with this after that
also our mind is in a very fragmented
State and we are kind of incapable of
doing anything productive or useful for
a long time so it's like a double snc of
time even after we end it we are
incapable of overcoming it overcoming
the bad effects from it so how do we
really get out of this if we are already
addicted to such kind of scrolling
mindlessly overnight it is not going
going to stop and and the problem here
is that this is so very easy to do this
mindlessly scrolling through the feed it
is so very easy to do so whenever uh we
feel that we are slightly stressed or we
do not want to do something difficult
with our work or studies we feel like
okay I'll just take a quick scroll U and
then it just unravels from there now how
do we go go come come come out of this
well some students try this actually uh
that they set a timer to it well setting
a timer in your mobile phone itself can
actually not benefit you that much
because it is very easy to snooze it or
maybe even to dismiss that timer if you
set up the alarm for maybe you say that
okay I will scroll but I will scroll
only for maybe 15 minutes or 20 minutes
and if you set the alarm for that so 20
minutes later when the alarm goes off
you snooze it it's very easy to do it so
my suggestion would be that maybe set up
a physical alarm maybe somewhere
slightly away from where you are sitting
maybe if you're sitting on your bed
scrolling through it just having some
mindless fun maybe keep the alarm clock
the 20-minute alarm clock some somewhere
on your table maybe a few feet away so
when it goes off you have to actually
physically get off from the bed uh that
it's a break in the in the Mindless
scrolling you have to physically even if
you snooze it you'll have to physically
go there and snooze it so I I hope that
uh that'll maybe help you take a step
towards actually breaking yourself free
from that mindless scrolling cycle uh
another thing is that you have to admit
to yourself that you are not going a not
going to be able to completely break
free from it this mindless scrolling if
you're already addicted to it so what
can help probably is that you set aside
a dedicated time for such kind of Doom
scrolling you tell yourself that yes I
will do it I will indulge in this
unhealthy habit but I will indulge it in
this dedicated time only so maybe for
that half an hour you just give yourself
into that guilty pleasure of Doom
scrolling but other than that you will
tell yourself no I have that dedicated
time I will not do do it now I'll do it
later on that is my time for I will
mindlessly indulge in that guilty
pleasure it's it's it's not the best of
fixes but it is a kind of a hack that
was about do scrolling the next thing I
want to discuss is our habit with
Facebook and please note that I'm not
referring to just any social media but
rather very specifically Facebook or
something which is closely related to
Facebook but I'm sure this is the most
popular one please don't get me wrong I
personally believe that Facebook is a
great platform but for making a uh
perhaps new connections but most
importantly for renewing the connections
that we may have lost maybe I had a
friend at school with whom I have
completely lost touch Facebook is a
great platform to renew that connection
it is absolutely fabulous but it is not
that great a platform uh if you are
using it to look into the personal lives
of others I was a heavy user of Facebook
long long time ago maybe 10 years ago
and I also looked at my friends personal
lives whatever they shared but uh over
the last 5 6 years I have simply given
up on that habit I mean I don't see the
point of doing it people with whom I'm
close I already know what they want to
share through direct
interaction I don't need to look at
Facebook and I'm sure many people who
are my age and maybe even much younger
to me also they are taking up this
philosophy ophy uh so think about it you
really don't need to look into the lives
of
others and please not that this lives of
others is not the real life that is
actually going on it is kind of what is
presented to us I'm sure you know about
all of this uh another thing which is
really bad on Facebook is um the
so-called quote unquote news that you
get it is absolutely the worst place to
get your news from I again I have myself
been guilty of this about 10 years ago I
I used to depend on Facebook for my news
feed that was a mistake okay if you
really if you're really after news go
read a newspaper get an online
subscription uh I would even say that
please do not watch news on YouTube the
thing is that whenever it is some sort
of a video I have I have noticed that it
is extremely polarized uh extremely
biased so maybe read a newspaper where
you'll get a more balanced view this is
my opinion regarding the the the news
aspect of Facebook but I think at the
end of the day if you really want to
indulge in some kind
of like a Mindless
scrolling if you have to indulge in
social media activity you better do this
on
YouTube instead of on Facebook better do
this on Twitter where there is more um
more informed opinion there are proper
experts there who who share their
opinions there who shared many things
there uh go on Twitter if you're into
text instead of videos go there and uh
engage there instead of on Facebook this
is my personal opinion after Breaking
Free from the Facebook thing what I
would like to suggest uh is that try to
break free from the algorithm and this
uh is true even on YouTube especially on
YouTube I would say our tastes our
preferences are are our own but the
algorithm is programmed in such a way so
as to fine-tune the presentation and the
serving of the various things to watch
uh by guessing what our preferences and
tastes are so we lose control over what
we are
watching now the problem is a little bit
um subtle and Insidious in the following
way suppose you go and watch a
entertainment or an infotainment video
and there are lots of them with millions
and millions of views they are I mean
please don't get me wrong they are
absolutely fun to watch they are
absolutely of extremely high quality uh
well researched uh very high production
quality they are extremely informative
there is no doubt about it uh and you
certainly I mean when you're watching it
you feel like you are learning many
things from it and on top of that the
host or the or the team of hosts they
are extremely likable and they're very
good presenters uh and uh it is really
fun to watch overall so when you watch
one such video the YouTube algorithm or
whatever the platform you are that that
algorithm it uh it serves another video
you watch that again and then it serves
you another video you watch that and it
goes on on on and on now you may think
so what's the harm you are after all uh
I mean engaging in in a thing which is
after all educative in nature what's the
harm in that and some of these videos
are present in such a fashion it it
seems to you that it they are much
better presented than what is presented
in your schools and colleges so why not
watch them and learn from
them well if you are actively learning
from them like if you're seeking out a
certain concept and one of those videos
maybe those math videos from uh three
blue one brown I believe that's the name
of the channel uh if you're maybe trying
to understand FIA transforms and you
watch one of his videos then it is
certainly an active learning and you
certainly gain to uh learn a lot I mean
a new way of understanding things but if
you are just mindlessly uh watching
things which the YouTube algorithm is
presenting to you then just pause for a
second and think how much of the things
which you are just looking at and not
really actively watching and learning
from how much of it are you actually
retaining can you even recall after a
day or two what you thought you had
learned from those videos and if not if
the answer is no if you cannot recall
those things then what is the point of
investing so much time in watching video
after video of these things which seem
apparently extremely useful but then
there is I mean there is no real value
addition to your uh learning this is my
question to you
so even though something is not
apparently uh useless but it can turn
out to be
so so think about it so what I'm trying
to say here is that these videos these
entertainment videos they themselves are
not at all useless of course they're
useful but the way that you engage with
them that is where the problem lies so
they make they make you feel really good
about yourself
but you are not really learning anything
if you're not actively seeking out the
knowledge and if you're not maybe taking
notes or um trying to retain very active
uh in a very active fashion so what is
the fix well uh we have to stop being a
slave to the YouTube algorithm or
whatever the platform it is so the way
that we can go about fixing it is by
taking active control and making our own
lists of videos that we prefer to watch
making a list of the things that we wish
to read from the various blog like
websites see this YouTube algorithm or
whatever the algorithm is it
is uh it is programmed to give us a
curated list based on what it guesses to
be our tastes and preferences what I'm
saying is that we take active control of
our own tastes and preferences and make
our own curated list curated means
systematically collecting something
organizing something arranging something
so this is the way to break free from it
and now initially this task may seem uh
I mean quite daunting but as our list
grows and grows what we what what we can
do is anytime we have this urge of
stopping our work or our studies and
just maybe engaging in this kind of a
quote unquote useful activity of uh
watching something like an entertainment
or an enertainment video instead of
letting the uh the algorithm dictate to
us what to watch we can go to our own
self-curated list and pick out something
which we had earlier decided would be
actually useful for us to watch there is
a very very subtle difference which I
hope hope you uh you'll be able to
appreciate another thing
is I've seen that it helps us to get out
of this uh cycle of being served by the
different algorithms if we actively seek
out a certain series of knowledge topics
what I mean by that is for example you
are interested in the history of
something uh maybe in the Napoleonic
worse so instead of arbitrarily letting
the Fe
uh servers videos you you make a list of
very focused type of videos which you
want to watch on that particular topic
and maybe you make different kinds of
playlists of the different things so
when you want to take a break from your
work and studies maybe go and uh watch a
video in the sequence that you have
arranged it from a certain playlist and
it it will certainly help you it has
helped me
uh when we try to finish a certain topic
so this kind of a focused watching uh
helps you maintain a certain continuity
it a coherence in the body of knowledge
that you are trying to pick up from and
even in the entertainment value instead
of constantly context switching so this
kind of a context switching it really
helps I mean it really creates a
fragment mentation in your brain after
which it is hard to recover for actual
productive work and if you really want
to uh read up a little bit more on these
kinds of ideas uh regarding
fragmentation context switching uh you
can certainly take a look at the videos
by Professor Cal Newport uh he has a
YouTube channel and uh even earlier than
that much much earlier than that in the
' 80s there was this book uh amusing
ourselves to death by Neil Postman uh it
was a wonderfully preent book which is
extremely relevant for our current times
also which touches upon uh these kinds
of things in a completely different
technological context but I think they
are absolutely relevant for these for uh
for our current times
also uh and finally uh I have said a lot
about breaking free from the algorithm I
would just like to say that there could
be a counterargument to this and that is
uh if we are trying to break free from
this
algorithm then the biggest advantage
that the algorithm gives us and that is
serving some Absolutely Fresh kind of
videos and getting us aware of uh
certain channels which we would
otherwise never be aware of how are we
going to take advantage of that true I
absolutely agree and for that the
solution is that you set aside a time
where you don't have to go to your own
self-curated list rather you let the
YouTube algorithm or whatever the
algorithm it is to serve to you and you
enjoy this part of the social media in a
completely exploratory fashion to
discover new things which you may be
completely unaware of so that kind of an
expiratory thing when you do it in a
well-intentioned
uh actively controlled way that yes you
are seeking it out you are you you are
letting the the the algorithm serve you
like literally serve you I think that is
taking back control itself okay this
kind of an exploratory thing is also
taking back control so definitely there
is no harm in doing that so all right I
have uh only this bunch of ideas to
share with you and I hope maybe a couple
of these ideas will help you to manage
your habits a little bit better and and
I realized that uh by this age that just
making some kind of a groundbreaking New
Year's resolution is not going to help
me change my habits so the best thing
that I can do is to uh try to manage my
habits in an incremental fashion and
towards this end I hope this video will
be helpful to you thank you and all the
best and all the best for the new year